ladies and gentlemen this is earth 2 a
virtual
version of the earth which claims to
have the same land
the same seas and even the same
heights now how it works their little
gimmick is they divide it up
and then they sell the land guys
sell imaginary land on their servers
so is it worth it what do you what do
you guys think we're going to talk about
it
today and the first thing i want to show
you is basically how it works by
actually buying something because you
know what day it is
it's webinar wednesday which means we
get scammed so you don't have to
so let's go over here this is the place
that i would like to buy
it is currently the old house of dan lok
dan lok apparently didn't pay rent
allegedly
allegedly and i want to buy his former
mansion
okay so i found the address i picked out
the little mcmansion
now the problem is is that it's
expensive as hell
this land so how it works i don't know
if you can see right here but
one tile costs seven dollars i've only
loaded up ten dollars on my
on my thing all together so i could i'm
literally gonna buy his pool
i don't know if that's is that his pool
that's basically his pull right pay with
account balance
yes all right i am the official owner
of this little dan lok's old house or at
least
a 10 by 10 of dan lok's old house now
now that's just one example of the
things you can buy
basically you can buy any piece of land
on the entire
earth supposedly so yeah that's
basically how you buy stuff
and a lot of you guys have been reaching
out to me this is like one of the most
popular websites in the last few days
and it has run one of the most
successful
game launches ever with one of the
people
in the discord chat of their thing who i
talked to about this because i was
curious why you would
buy this and i asked them how much
they're making recently it slowed down
to like i think the last couple days
it's been like
somewhere around the range of like 500
000 a day but
a couple weeks ago they were making a
million dollars a day okay so that's
obviously nuts like they're making
insane amounts of money all because
people
are going in and they're buying up
little tiles
of land this is where it gets dicey for
me
is why are people buying this land see
obviously a lot of this
is not bought but there are also parts
like this
part of the uh bridge san francisco
which
are bought so the question is why are
people buying it
what is this company doing i mean why
are they selling land
and they're pulling in one million
dollars a day
for 25 million dollars it's like one of
the most successful video game launches
ever so
25 million is me uh you know ballparking
at the last
actual numbers i got was somewhere
around 20 million i think it was
oh wait wait did i mention yet that it's
it's all a video game okay
so hang on uh because yeah you're like
wait i thought it was a marketplace
no get this it's a video game too
look this these developers they're a bit
goofy because they kind of want to be
everything this guy official david lamar
uh puts it really well
that's where they kind of talk a little
bit about the business
and from what it sounds like they want
to be a mixture of simcity
the sims second life minecraft
um what's that other big game um
grand theft auto you guys know no big
deal
just a combination of all the aaa games
and just be
all of those as a game studio or well
it's not even a game studio really
it's like like 11 developers or whatever
work on it like a team of 11.
and look i know at this point your head
is screaming
scam but am i look honestly mine is too
when you go look at their team they got
some heavy hitters here they got the
co-founder of oculus here
uh which that's a pretty big get and
obviously they have money to pay
developers now since they just
speed ran the basically the fastest 25
million dollar
uh investment deal ever from like micro
investing
but kind of where i take issue with it
is that people have put in this money
for seemingly
all on a bet that this is gonna be the
greatest game ever
but there's no proof that it is i mean
you're really putting your hands you're
putting your uh bank account
in the hands of these developers so let
me say right up front lest anyone get it
twisted okay
if you go and you go to this place do
not
buy a single thing here's their
marketplace or whatever you supposedly
can buy
sell land that's the only way you can
get your money out of this if you sell
land
but don't put money on this unless
you're prepared to lose it because
bottom line what you're actually doing
if you buy into earth 2.0
you're supporting a video game
development and it's like the pre-alpha
stage they don't even have an
alpha but you're basically supporting
that with the hopes that with adoption
maybe enough people will come in and
want to buy earth 2.0 land
because that's what it is it's like this
metaverse idea sort of like second life
where you can go and like chat with each
other i guess
but except it's in like a video game
that's real life
but still a video game and i guess you
own land like basically they're selling
the land to raise money for it it seems
like
so yeah if you get invested in this
thing if you're getting invested to make
money
sorry you're an idiot there's almost no
way you're gonna pull your money out why
because of the supply look every kind of
thing where you're investing in it it's
got to have a supply side demand side
right
the demand for earth two tiles is even
at 25 million dollars
is relatively low right um because if
you just think about it for a second at
10 cents a tile which they're a lot more
than that as you saw because they go up
in values more people buy it
but at 10 cents in a tile you're talking
about
250 million tiles of demand right now
how many tiles is earth 2 currently
supporting according to this youtuber 51
billion
10 tiles per square kilometer so
i divided it by 10 and figured out that
there's 51 billion
tiles on earth now okay so
so let's repeat that again you should do
one billion tiles
and the demand is while it's initially
really high
uh it's obviously finite so you have a
near infinite amount of supply
where you could spend five billion
dollars in the game and still not get
all the tiles
and then what the demand is like really
finite i don't know that to me
immediately
raises serious red flags because who's
gonna unload your land from you
why are they gonna buy your land over
the 50 000 other people who want to sell
their land that day it makes
no sense and this is my first big gripe
with the game is that a lot of people
are pushing this as it's like some
investment opportunity
uh so first off if you could just like
my video and subscribe to the channel
for more earth 2 content we're going to
make each other millionaires
wait wait what look listen i'm all fine
with supporting some video game by
giving them money when they don't really
have a product yet
really but make each other millionaires
this is delusional
and it honestly reminds me a lot i mean
there have been a lot of projects like
this right where people sell like
virtual land
and people think oh i'm gonna jump in on
that and get rich obviously it
ends up burning a lot of people this is
decentraland
a virtual world that's owned by its
users sound familiar i'm not selling it
until it's worth at least 10 million
they're the riskiest investments in the
whole world look at that
look at that that brilliant edit this
guy's like i'm holding on to it
till 10 million and then the next guy's
like it's the riskiest investment in the
entire world
yeah um i wouldn't even classify this as
an investment
you're spending money on a video game
look at it like a skin
in fortnite or csgo but then pretend
that csgo and fortnite is not a
functional game yet
that's essentially what you seem to be
buying here
and i'm not gonna pretend to understand
the psychology of
you know spending a bunch of money on
games like these because literally if
you look at the leaderboard
there are multiple people who have spent
uh ninety thousand dollars
and more all these people are celebrated
for spending like huge amounts in the
game but
it's like dude this game didn't exist
like two months ago
it came out november 2020
[Music]
and people have already dropped 80 000
on it
75 000 and i have to wonder like would
they have done that if they didn't think
they were gonna make money off of it
that's what i think is the biggest part
of the scam is that people are thinking
they're gonna make their money back
and honestly they're not if you look at
it as like you're investing in
developers that's fine
but if you look at it like i'm spending
eighty thousand dollars and i'm gonna
get my money back
i don't know this is another youtuber
named matt lorraine
who uh has also been making earth 2.0
content and he also
says like how do you make money in earth
2.0 i haven't showed you the best way to
make money in earth too
and that's you're not making money on
earth too or at least
you're very unlikely again guys
uh just be careful there's so many scams
out there and
the thing is is that this it's hard to
call it a scam because it depends on the
reason you're buying it
if you're buying it because you want to
make money selling the land later you're
almost for sure getting scammed
i mean it's almost for sure there's just
not going to be demand for your
little land whatever because literally
the marketplace is set by earth 2.
there's no real
value to these tiles right they're just
making it up as they go
but if you want to support a like highly
ambitious game
and alpha with a pretty unknown dev team
i think you just have to be interested
in all that you know
metaverse stuff talking games that kind
of stuff
but um yeah i mean i'm not gonna pretend
like i fully
understand this but what i do know is
that i'm now the proud owner of dan
lok's house
on earth too i don't plan on ever
selling it don't ask me
but uh yeah let me know what you think
in the comments below i know some of you
earth 2 fanboys out there
are going to be shocked that i made this
video and i want to hear from you guys
i mean how insane is it that a company
with no video game no real product
has already raised allegedly 20 to 25
million dollars
so 25 million is me uh you know
ballparking at the last
actual numbers i got was somewhere
around 20 million i think it was
i mean this is like bigger than star
citizen almost
so yeah i don't know we'll see let me
know what you think in the comments
below
and i'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
you